uh well yesterday was my
eight years off of alcohol yesterday i
hit eight years i hit eight [ __ ]
times dude yes he keeps trying to smell
that tiger thick i'm like dude stay away
from get your relapse sam tripoli just
duke posted that he's been off porn for
like like i don't know a month or
something wait what all right
he's trying to get rid of this maniac if
you have to stay with me one time he
goes no i'm weird what does on porn mean
like he's just [ __ ] i think he's
watched all the porn and now he says
he's gone he's not drinking he's not
he's he's been sober for a year he's not
eating like sugar he's lost yeah he's
lost like some 40 pounds and he's not
watching porn anymore i uh i tried a few
weeks ago i tried a non-alcoholic beer
no if i reminisce the point bro it was
yeah i was like oh no i can't do this
they gave me sick i was like if i have
like
another one of these i'll [ __ ] well i
had a sip of it and i was like if i
drink a full one
it was we were at a vegan joint i was
with uh jason ellis and uh toby and
someone was like get uh
jason ellis got it he got a
non-alcoholic i'll try that i was like
i'll try a sip of it just and it was i
was like man if i had
all of that it's like being a vegetarian
and then you eat that fake meat just
don't eat the meat you know that fake
meat daddy daddy uh i forgot to tell you
this daddy went down the rabbit hole
thank you daddy went down the rabbit
hole it's hot as [ __ ] huh no daddy went
down rabbit hole this weekend daddy got
back into a little dmt
oh you did one answer or did some
mushrooms you did dmt without me
i did but i'll i'll get you involved no
no i don't want to involve come on
they've cheated on me
those are things i know dude i'll get
let me get you back involved you were in
mexico and i said i had an opportunity
to do actual dmt and i was like tell us
about the trip what happened you know
wait here's hon where'd you do it set it
up i did it in vegas okay what were you
doing in vegas i was with the tourhole
oh
not that well though no this one person
i know very well who do i know i'll tell
ya
what do i know um you cheated on me with
the dna
but i don't wanna i don't wanna add them
because i don't i haven't asked them if
it's okay
uh i i do mushrooms which i've done
plenty of times but not for years yeah
before you go uh micro dosing or like
full blown i did a micro dose but i did
a little more than a microphone feel it
until i did feel it and then i went oh
i'm i'm why am i staring at that
mountain for too long but where are you
at when you did this i was in the shop
when my buddy was making my flip-flops
a.g was making my flip-flops okay and so
as he's making my flip-flops you know
it's a it's a it's a hand he does it all
by hand so he's clipping he's cutting
and i was like this is too much man
yeah everything is moving too quickly
yeah and then i uh but but here's the
thing dmt awesome mushrooms awesome you
know what
i'm too old to have a life-changing
experience oh yeah no you know that that
ship sailed yeah right yeah yeah when
you're young and that's what it's
supposed to do
that's how i feel about your braces you
know yes yeah well no hold on who's who
was like hey dude
let's watch this man make leather
sandals and do shrooms
that was me
that'd be me
you wanted to have some fun i just i
would have been i'd be like well i'm not
doing this i had an opportunity
to micro dose and i said i'll take one
of those
let me see what micro doses the pill or
chocolate the pill a little a little
much though a little more than a micro
dose and that's what happened and i got
kind of into you know but what's really
interesting about mushrooms and they
can't figure out what it is and i heard
jordan peterson talking about it is that
when people have um cancer and it's an
uncertain diagnosis they might die
whatever
they found and people with ptsd they
found at psilocybin trips even one if
done properly
can literally
change your neural chemistry or do
whatever it does to you where people are
simply and many times no longer afraid
of death yeah and accept their death in
in a way yeah and and it really has and
i i don't i'm not privy to these
experiments but there has been
measurable evidence that it [ __ ]
really does help in
some cases
ptsd
yeah big time that's why and they don't
know why they don't know why but they
know that there are there are different
levels of consciousness well there are
different levels of consciousness we
don't the brain itself that they were
talking about is is it like if you look
at the bottom of the ocean the deepest
ocean we don't know [ __ ] about it it's
like the brain is even more of a mystery
but we do know you can you can you can
have
uh episodes of consciousness change the
road
yeah yeah but also also that are
positive not negative so it used to be
that when if you did a trip it was like
considered it's going to be negative not
so that the shift in scientific thinking
is it actually can be a very attitude
going into it
so did you feel any what like
i appreciate i like psychedelics no no
did you have like any any type of
experience to where like you felt
something
life change
at 55. you want to know my real my my
real opinion on [ __ ] everything in
psychedelics
i think i think psychedelics are there
no i think i think that they're there
because
they bring you back to the original
idea of god
in other words
if you if you really like if you really
like
get the through line of all the
religious traditions yeah in a lot of
ways people who come out of psychedelic
trips go i think there's something to
that [ __ ] that's going on there there i
think there's something to stuff like
that
yeah
a lack of a lot not as afraid of death
sure sure
can you set the dmt uh table first how'd
that go down when you cheated on me dmt
last time we did we had a shaman
yeah dmt is about dmt is about as
euphoric as you can get you kind of
leave your body
and did you smoke it again yeah and
where and how was this time
did you cry did you laugh as hard as we
did i think i saw what i'm the most
afraid of and i need to go into what
that's about wow so so carl jung said
did you see a crocodile or something
stupid i did i saw a croc i was looking
at the globe
and all the clouds came together it's
funny
and they showed the top of a crocodile
really and i went wow well we know how
this ends you swim with the crawl i
gotta swim
i gotta spin with the crocs
like why why no
they're like [ __ ] your ex this is my
journey i'm like let me is faces of
death still available
for content and while i was on my dmt
thing i went i went i literally went
man if i jumped in the water with a croc
right now it would still suck all the
dick
would be terrified